in this video you're going to see a lot
of secret information we know we can
trust you to keep it a secret
fun fact for you did you know that in
the past year our audience has grown
more than it has in the previous nine
years combined nine years you're telling
us we've been well established and had a
large team of talented filmmakers by our
side for ten years no that took about
five years to get to that point
ten years ago may 17 2010 that's when he
started the corridor digital youtube
channel and here we are a decade later
it's interesting because on our 10-year
anniversary nico
is moving out i've been in this building
ever since we moved to los angeles
corridor digital started in the loft
that i currently live in before we moved
it over to studio number four with that
change will come a lot of changes for
the studio it's been a crazy time and i
want to tell you a bit of a personal
story in this video and take you guys on
the journey of what started as just two
kids from minnesota and turned into a
whole group of filmmakers being really
passionate about the stuff they make and
having an awesome audience to make it
for let's go on a journey
all right
so on the other side of the store
sam myself freddie and brandon
all got a place together as roommates
because we're working on a film a
monster movie called dark island and
that then turned into youtube
someone's moving yeah
getting out of here yeah pardon the mess
by the way but this is what happens when
you're moving right now it actually
looks like how it looked when corridor
was here
studio three is great you know this is
where all like the old school videos are
if you're like an old school freddy w
and quarter digital fan from like the
2010 to 2012 era you know studio three
this was the place we even shot full-on
quarter digital videos there like googly
eyes
[Music]
in this part of la this was literally
the cheapest building and some of you
guys might know that our landlord is a
artist i am not just any landlord i am
steve the landlord he has made it his
goal to keep the rent low in this
building us being two bumpkins from the
midwest really appreciated that we
didn't have jobs we didn't have a place
to live we could happen to afford enough
room to actually set up green screens
store props do all that stuff and really
get a head start things kind of kicked
off when i was right here sitting on a
couch it wasn't this couch it's a
different couch freddy's desk was right
here in fact you can still see the worn
out floor from the wheels of freddie's
chair this is where old friends had his
rocking chair sam and i were working on
this video idea and we wanted to make
this little like tactical military piece
and freddie said you know what why don't
you make a fan film for call of duty
have a little more audience appeal
you're like that's a good idea
it's right here when that happened we
went off and shot that over christmas
because we needed a break we've been
working on dark island for a year and we
just wanted to go and make something for
fun and the idea of making a call of
duty fan film ended up working out
really well for us the day we released
it it was number one on reddit for the
entire day we got a million views in a
day which was a big deal on youtube back
then our first video happened to go
viral which is pretty solid it's on the
freddie w channel oh yeah because it
cost us like about 325 dollars i think
and we wanted to get the money back
we're really going all in for this one
yeah and freddie's like you know we put
our channel we just got partnered like
back in the day if you want your channel
your video to be monetized you have to
wait for someone to manually review it
like two days after you uploaded it
start getting ads a couple days after
it's uploaded so when frozen crossing
won went live and went viral it got a
million views in the first day we didn't
make any money off of that that's okay
because we had to re-upload it remember
there's a lot of history here i remember
there's like a big barrel of guns there
or something that one over there oh
there's the barrel there the barrel was
always here in fact we filled it with
coins because we figured like a barrel
needed treasure let's see if the
questions are still there
someone said coins where the gold
you filled it with coins oh there's like
such a pitiful amount of coins in there
it's a big barrel see there's
commemorative la olympics coins in there
from 1988 as well as a flattened penny
1895 something something greenfield
village i have no idea where that is
got to seal it up keep the coins fresh
it's a great space to actually work in
the only problem is that this was also
where sam and nico lived this was their
home when we moved in there's cubicles
that we had to tear down also this wall
here none of this was built by the way i
don't want to come back here it's too
hot this is why i left this is like a
big wide open area my mattress was in
one corner sam's mattress was in the
other corner freddy's mattress was in
one corner and brandon's mattress was in
a different corner and because i was
always the youngest they uh decided to
turn this into the baby's room
replaced my old bed with a tiny baby bed
maybe memorabilia basically one of the
first things we did when we moved here
is we built these walls in the back
divvied up the spaces everyone needed
their private space because literally it
was like the four of us all sleeping on
mattresses on opposite ends of this like
thousand square foot room no privacy
this is the prop room or was the we
still call it the prop closet you know
there's no props in there anymore this
was originally freddy and jimmy's room
and they had a bunk bed but they had so
much stuff they had to store that they
just put all that on the top and just
shared the bottom bunk so we talked
about creating a secret youtube channel
called two wong's make a right it's just
video of them sleeping together
never did it but we did end up making a
really fun video where we had a fake gun
wall that like spun around to like show
our cool guns that like tricked
everybody to think that we like that
jake built a real mechanized gun wall we
initially moved in there was like just a
metal pole that was left from the
previous tenant and brandon had the idea
of making a pull-up bar so i spent like
an hour cutting through it with a
hacksaw it's been here ever since for us
to do workouts on i did the upside down
ones flip your toes underneath and
do it upside down so we were living and
working on the same space and that was
one of the things that we could do in
this area this is known as artists lofts
live work spaces you can actually run a
business and to live in the same space
which is actually illegal in much of la
occasionally fans would you know find
the address and usually be outside or
something like that but one saturday
morning i'm sitting on the couch i'm in
like gym shorts sam's in the kitchen
making coffee or something like that and
the door
opens and in steps like a family from
ohio or something like that and the
dad's just like
wow
so this is where the magic happens and
like i said from the couch and like this
is like saturday morning and sam like
walks out of the kitchen like hi
like if the kid who was there who took
his picture with us if you are watching
this video still you owe it to us to put
it on instagram and tag cord or digital
heck take me take sam i want to see that
picture i want to see how frazzled
and out of it i look were you worried
that it wouldn't work out i don't worry
about things not working out that often
maybe more so as i've gotten a little
wiser but back then there were so many
fallbacks still yeah if youtube doesn't
work out we were making just enough
money doing freelance visual effects and
still know a bunch of people there i
always move back home at the end of the
day we haven't like burned those bridges
yet so it's like not to mention like
just simply being in a space where
there's other people doing it there's
that kind of support back then it was so
hard to even put a gauge on success or
failure for this kind of stuff because
there wasn't like any similar content
out there to gauge it against oh it felt
like a win-win you guys might wonder
where jake plays into all this so jake
is also from the same hometown he
wouldn't use the same grade as us when
he's in high school and he's already out
here going to law school jake's always
wanted to do this kind of thing like you
know making art but also helping
shepherd it because that's kind of
jake's personality like he's a german
shepherd of a human being basically fill
in with us right away because he just
wanted to help us make videos
and very quickly stepped up to become a
producer and just help us run the
business in time he eventually became
the third partner of corridor but you
can see jake as well as us in uh videos
on our channel it was on the freddie w-2
channel which became the brandon jla
channel it's the water bucket prank and
it was one of like the first videos to
like really go viral and get out of like
our circle of like visual effects short
films
there's a moment the camera pans around
the room you can see me see jake see sam
all of us is just like little children i
think jake has a ponytail this whole
place here this was our sniper zone the
street was very empty back in the day we
had a 60 foot like range from building
to building here where we could test out
airsoft guns boy have times changed not
every shot was true i think the best
range though was when we were working on
there's an alien on your head with clint
dude
there's like an alien on your head
we'll get it off
and that video is inspired from us
playing archery in here you know i mean
it's hard to miss at this range we were
training for eventually doing the
william tell challenge which is to shoot
an apple off of somebody's head for a
while we had like a helmet set up and
like the target on top of the helmet and
the rules never hit the helmet every
shot must be on the target exactly and
you're good and so then we made a video
about that there's a part where i needed
to get shot with an arrow and didn't we
just actually shoot me with an arrow
yeah we could have done the head shot
but like it was way safer to do the
chest soft target you're wearing a vest
etc aim it to your right clint two one
two
oh
are you all right it was pretty cool
actually shooting nico with a real arrow
just like we shot peter
it was the same thing we'll create a
playlist of all the memories and all the
videos that we're talking about the
memory that really stands out to me is
when you're going to go out and shoot
our brand deal for assassin's creed for
black flag so ubisoft had actually given
us a pretty solid budget to shoot a
cinematic video and we had rented actual
tall ships to go out and film upon that
would be out on the ocean with like
actual crews and pirates we were
shooting an actual big budget thing at
that point you know something we had
been dreaming of doing forever and we
had all of our gear laid out here like
this whole place just filled with boxes
and like we're trying to live here at
the same time not just me and sam like
four people it was right around the time
studio four opened up so studio 4 is
another unit in this building it's
actually on the other side wall it's a
studio that you guys see in all the
videos and the idea of having a studio
where we could work in another place
where we could live and not having them
be the same spot was starting to get
really appealing and it was just shortly
after that that we ended up renting
studio four that started the whole era
of you know the new quarter crew videos
the new corridor videos all the things
that you guys basically know us for now
so the craziest thing about all this
youtube stuff is that i never expected
to be doing this for more than like two
or three years i always felt like oh
this is just like a stop gap as we
figure things out before we get work on
a movie set or work for a studio or you
know somebody hires us to maybe work on
a tv show or something like that like
we've done a series and we've done
movies you do them and then it's like
well
now what
let's keep doing youtube i think the
reason we keep coming back to it is
because of you guys because the audience
because as an artist there's nothing
more rewarding than having people watch
your work it's easy to forget all that
and not be thankful for how amazing
youtube is for artists you look at wren
and how he's gone from doing behind the
scenes on the sam nico channel to doing
visual effects on the corridor channel
and now doing educational science based
videos on the core crew channel i guess
our attitude with corridor has always
been to make it a thing that helps us do
what we want to do try to find a way to
deliver the art to the people that want
to see it and at the end they make the
art that you want to make why do you
care about what we do here why do you
come watch it why do you why do you why
did you listen to us tell the story of
corridor i'd be curious
to know why this is getting really deep
hey man we've been doing this for 10
years like i've spent a third of my
lifetime doing this it's crazy i started
making videos with sam when i was 14. i
guess it's a 20 year anniversary of us
making videos together yeah that is 20
year anniversary of making videos
so behind this american flag is studio
number three the place we just toured
it's our intention right now that when
nego leaves that we take our studio and
we begin using that space as part of it
maybe we'll have more space to do cool
things maybe we can get that archery
range back a green screen a slide
probably a rope who knows hey maybe the
guillotine channel will get filmed again
over the past two years we basically
doubled in personnel and now we'll
double up in size it was getting pretty
crowded that everybody's at home right
now so it's not as crowded as it used to
be but
back in 2008 there was five buddies that
pursued their dreams of filmmaking down
here at hunter street and one by one
they left
jimmy
wong
out freddie wong
out
brandon lodge out
myself sam
out and all there was that remained was
nico until now and he is finally left to
become a fully grown man
no longer will he live in the apartment
with all his post-college mid-20s
memories and so for that i feel like we
should pour one out
i don't know i feel like we just got
relegated to like little square on the
end card while we're pouring that
i could feel myself shrinking down into
the end corner of the screen there as we
report now
you guys like oh this is it all i gotta
say is if you enjoyed our stuff please
consider subscribing it's been a great
10 years i look forward to many more
yeah
[Music]
i love you
it's kind of a huge commitment niko